I think Magnus is going to use his Pawn
to divert that night away and and when
he does that it does seem like it should
be winning okay so after the trade upon
suddenly the table base this in-game
database where everything has been
worked out came into force and uh well
his last move was a mistake his Rook
move and uh now upon this position black
can actually win for reasons I don't
know but he could actually put the queen
to D5 and that would have been a win
after this move it's a draw but still
not an easy draw I mean this is the kind
of move I think you mentioned David at
one of magnus's favorite moves you allow
a discovered check so wherever the
Knight moves the black king is in check
but even that to draw that I mean I
would assume this position is completely
winning if I look to this I'd be like
how old it's a losing one no yeah
Knights on the edge of the board I mean
this one also looks odd yeah I mean the
Knight is almost trapping itself I guess
it's gonna go to this F5 Square which we
which we normally love but but this is
like the beauty of Chess and like the
Wonder riddle antagonist's natural king
move that was also a mistake and now the
position is only drawn this is evil I
mean table based computers we should
explain to some of the viewers who may
be new to trust what table base is it's
when I think there's seven pieces or
fewer and that has been worked out just
mathematically by computers uh they've
worked out what the best moves are for
each side on every turn so objectively
with best play I'm not sure is it still
a draw it's still a draw now a draw yeah
it must be a way to push it this is the
thing if I think if black cow or what he
can push it now but it gets captured if
oh Ivan trick maybe he's found oh a way
to draw maybe this is the drawing idea
with the white king coming forwards
you're really containing that pawn so uh
I it might be a blockade uh that that
we've got here in this position
um you can give a track and repeat the
position if Andrew does this he checks
the King has to go back and he'll repeat
uh okay the King goes back in a
different way uh we should also mention
that taking this Knight is a draw uh
it's king and porn but the white king is
safely in front of the black porn so
um study your king of bowling games this
one is a draw you just need to know
where to go with the white king
so Magnus won't go for this
the current position it's all about this
G3 square right yeah
so this is probably why that king move
was a mistake by Magnus putting the King
on the G line well maybe those moves in
there you can go around again yeah it's
going to say exactly the same thing this
the king is in the worst Square
um if you can get the king to avoid that
trick you might be able to push the pawn
this is uh and he's trying it so he's
trying to get the King around now at
some point that black pawn
maybe can come forwards right yeah if
you can push it Forward safely he's
going to win Magnus but yeah okay right
check discover check apparently still
safe
wow he's really defending uh like a lion
here van trick he's going to drop his
Knight back and he's just gonna sit and
maybe maybe he's waiting maybe that's a
Fortress Yeah
Simon hasn't watched The Full Monty I
found out today either oh I haven't
maybe tonight I thought that was uh you
had to do that in school in England or
something yeah I think it's a very
English film right so yeah maybe not
primary school I guess
it came out when we were at University
right so that's not an excuse I think uh
isn't that like one of Magnus Carlson's
favorite movies of all time yeah
probably I've never discussed it I think
but meanwhile this Fortress continues
evantric he did it kind of the long way
around he brought his like the whole way
around the board but he's found the
ideal defensive Square for it but Magnus
doesn't believe in fortresses
they do they certainly do so how many
moves have we got Dave because the the
rule in chess is
um if there's no capture so that means
no pieces are are taken off the board or
there's no Pawn moose if you have 50
moves that happen like that the game is
a draw so um that could well happen here
because there's no reason at all Magnus
will agree to a draw they're gonna have
to play it out because obviously white
can make a mistake uh Black's last pawn
move the last pawn move or capture was
moved 72 right so uh so we've got
122 yes to get to before a draw can be
claimed so it's about to be moved 90 so
we'll have 32 moves left wow if vantrik
needs to survive 32 moves without
allowing a capture of one of his pieces
or the black pawn from pushing yeah but
Magnus is like trying everything you
know if the if the black king can at the
right moment come maybe one square
forwards uh then it'd be potentially
winning if the black porn can step one
square forwards it'd be potentially
winning so there's still danger here but
Chucky seems to know what he's doing
it's a Chucky Fortress you know no one
gets through a Chuck Fortress Yeah he
has to kind of maintain that
configuration so the only the only few
moves that he can play is that moves the
Knight to the G3 Square yeah and uh
Magnus giving a check
oh this looks good scary
kind of again curl itself up again and
defend the night Rook goes to G2
this is like a type of Fortress where
the the gate like the door is made of
straw or something yes like at any
moment someone could just burst through
but definitely right now it's it's just
about holding and you can only really
move the Rook up and down one square
maybe the king but that looks so risky
um self-pinned you are it's but it's
holding it's holding doing the job
the White Knight is stuck so white has
to play around with his Rook Chuck
Fortress is the only Fortress you can
get what I mean great defensive play
though by by Chucky isn't it I mean we
we know that magnus's
uh the well probably the best end game
player in the world and and Chucky is
holding him yeah only three players have
been able to uh get a draw against
Magnus Carlsen in this Tournament of
course that loss against Neiman Let's uh
not take that into account So eventually
could be the fourth player here to get a
point against Magnus Carlsen
and Magnus seems to be running out of
ideas he's moving his King around but
it's a bit unclear what he's actually
doing with this can white just continue
waiting
White's root can step up white throat
can maybe step across I'm not sure how
narrow the margin for error is right now
I can tell you there's only three moves
and uh this Rook move was correct if
you'd move the Rook maybe off the G line
you would have lost wow that yeah that's
uh insane size Reiki I was very tempted
to move it over one square yeah me too
and uh but that was losing was it yes
or months of analysis to go into a deep
dive of this one but okay Adventure
because uh trying everything's nice I
mean if the black king can move one
square forwards that also looks like to
me should be waiting for black uh or
nearly winning
the important moment here just to kind
of say to you guys because if you step
back with the Rook to G1 he would have
lost this he still maintains The
Fortress it's okay and uh yeah he here
he has to move his work along the second
row he can also defend the Rook with his
King and it's still a draw you know so
that's the evangelic here is just
playing great chess he's defending like
a lion and let's just see what move
we're on remember if we get to move
there we have reached move 100 it's a
super long game the other games in round
um what is it round uh 11 correct has
started we're gonna jump into Niemann
aronian when this one finishes yeah yeah
I was thinking that really good point
you made Queen and porn against Rooker
Knight it should be winning right but if
we think about it white has two pieces
black has only two pieces I mean let's
discard the Kings so white has a Rooker
Knight they're both pretty good yes the
queen is better than the Rook but White
Knight is better than the black porn so
it kind of makes some sense I guess that
white is uh just about holding here of
course the queen is the best piece and I
think in Practical terms 90 something
percent of these games would end in a
black win but remember this is kind of
the top one percent of chess players in
the world this is the elite and if it if
it's objectively a correct draw then
advantric I mean so far he's done a good
job of proving that 20 moves to go he's
just you know he's done 30 moves already
so if he can do another 20 moves it will
be a drop just be uh called a draw and I
guess so the thing minus Crossing would
have to do to win this game would would
be to to get the white pieces out of the
eye line of that pool yeah if he can
somehow kick the white Pieces away I
think that's why as Ivanka mentions the
narrow uh the narrow path to survival
for white is just keeping this white
formation this defensive formation of
antrix found is perfect for stopping
that black pawn but if he can kick the
Pieces away or catch them at a moment
where they're kind of imbalance uh kind
of off balance
um then pushes Pawn himself then he
might win but if not then
Fortress and draw
I think if Andrew deserves the draw is
this one just for his defense I think
he's played it perfectly as well I've
been in so many little opportunities
which I didn't realize that you've
pointed out Ivanka where you can just
play one slightly bad move as white and
you you lose your Fortress but he hasn't
done that he's he's kept this harmony
between his three pieces but it really
is like an animal in his shell isn't it
here you really are just sort of moving
about in that shell trying to keep the
defense against the attacking Queen here
and here he goes I think he's gonna hold
it right I think he's going to hold this
drawer it's looking like he's found a
good way and he's navigating those traps
uh very very quickly and very easily as
well but still I I still think it's a
long long road ahead of him but Magnus
doesn't look like he's talked to Mystic
anymore he'd made some kind of gesture
there as if he's giving up uh giving up
the winning attempts
Decay The Night Moves Magnus hasn't made
any progress we should mention for those
last 35 moves so will we see that draw
soon and this game it's had like five or
six different phases it's like the
opening phase the middle game battle the
Queens came off it was still kind of
half a middle game half end game but
just the way the players kind of
transition and uh still so accurate it's
impressive
and Advantix built up two and a half
minutes on the clock as well as we
should mentioned uh he was down at a
couple of seconds not that long ago so
he's very confident right now I'm not
sure what else black can try as well I
mean black Magnus has tried everything
he's put his King on the other side of
the Pawn on this side of the pawn he's
trying to force his way through but uh
Chucky has stopped him every hurdle so
just don't blunder now Chuckie and you
can you got this you got this and I
think it was quite instructive on his
last move white just pushed his King to
the side he didn't go after the black
porn the white Rook could have actually
stepped up check a couple of moves ago
and taking that black porn but black uh
White would have lost all coordination
and the black king would have come in
now though black king is cut off by the
white Rook it's so important these
positions they need to keep keep your
knight broken and King all defending
each other you know when you're playing
against the queen you've got to keep
your pieces close you've got to keep
them defending because they can drop off
very very easily uh if you if you try
anything too too much and he's doing
that he's doing everything he's seen
this position before right it I I mean
if we see the position repeat itself
three times I think the game is
automatically declared to draw uh by the
server so
um yeah I mean we've seen something very
similar at least
and if ventric is is that the adrenaline
is he shaking his foot is that
respecting the whole computer vibrate
it's so full of energy
at a sprightly 53 years old
and uh yeah he's defending this one
still very well you can give a check
with the white Rook for example here
can you push the brook over to in front
of the king maybe get that get that
Fortress position again as well it would
also be a draw also checking the king
with and the Knight would also be a draw
but of course you have to be prepared to
set that Fortress up again
um yeah this is pretty much quite a few
moves draw it's not such a narrow path
it's an attack the black queen with a
white Rook as well if ventric do you
reckon he's just counting in his mind
how many moves it's been his memory is
very good yeah he could be working out
yeah often the top players they they can
scroll uh on the on the computer screen
and they can check when the last porn
move was made but often they just kind
of Play and play and they just believe
in their defense they don't worry about
the 50 move rule in Rapid Chess at least
of course only only 10 moves now 11 11
moves maybe to be totally accurate but
he's got to just survive for 11 moves
without a capture or a pawn push so we
can count them down now okay he's
getting closer getting close ten moves
to go
do you have another track or go and
attack the black queen with the white
Rook
those look like the most natural you th
the king back we've seen the black king
in this side of the board before yeah
and uh Magnus just he'll look to try and
set one final trap I don't see it to be
honest he's tried everything already
yeah but uh what a high quality game
yeah true grind like a grand master game
yeah I mean Magnus is doing the right
thing never give up chances just if you
have the advantage no risk try and play
for the win like maybe 10 games out of
100 he would have beaten a ventric here
but that's still a decent percentage
yeah this one is headed towards the draw
though
okay one chick will still be in the lead
in their head-to-head score in Rapid
chess 15 wins before this game and 13
for Magnus this will probably put
another draw on that list
yes and seven more moves seven more
moves
after Black's 120
will be automatically a draw unless
there is a pawn push
okay the Knight moving
slightly surprised by that one but it
looks like the Fortress is still intact
it's still holding it I think the Knight
can always come back I guess as well and
there's not long to go now and I think
Magnus must realize that this move 122
so
good thing that's a check otherwise
you'd lose because it's a nasty night
Fork there but uh you are checking the
king there so just uh
yeah the lights good yeah I mean how
narrow is the path now you might could
not narrower at all any king move any
Rook block is going to be a draw and he
chooses to make the Rook move
and King comes
forward let's see how this one works out
yeah I think we've seen something
similar at least before the white king
is doing a great job of protecting both
of its pieces at the same time
five moves we've been counting down five
reaction from these two when the game
finishes
it's lasted now for uh 70 minutes almost
120 move coming up or is that 120 that's
maybe it's only three moves now or two
moves so I can't count either black
makes three moves it will be a draw a
draw now at this point you can almost
nearly blunder a piece as long as black
doesn't have time to take it before the
102nd uh be risky blunder a piece and
try to press the draw button really
quickly
I had a rook and Bishop versus rooking
game my opponent made 49 moves and then
blundered his Rook on move 50 but before
I had time to take it I had to make my
50th move and take it on the 51st and he
claimed the drug playing the drawer and
uh he really pretended he did it by
accident
okay the game unless I'm coming wrong it
should be a draw after black after
Black's move now maybe Chucky wants to
play it on a little bit no Chucky
it is a draw after
123 moves in 17 minutes two legends in
chess the great muslimon shook with a
sigh of relief he gets a draw against
world number one Magnus calls an a great